one thing that we do notice is when
people are more Dynamic speakers when
they say something that's more
interesting and they're more engaging
people actually don't tend to note their
O's and um's as much as people that give
sort of a monotonous boring delivery and
maybe don't have content that's really
interesting so a lot depends on what
you're saying
what do you study
I am what's called a socio-linguist
don't try to say that after a few drinks
at cocktail parties it's a hard one but
it basically means that I study how the
underlying linguistic patterns that we
take for granted and we don't even
notice anymore vary not just by language
or dialect but by social facts about us
that are much smaller than these things
that we tend to think of as language
differences
why do languages change at all then why
isn't it just that we have a language
and then people use it and people use it
and it gets locked in for the rest of
time well that's why I make the big
bucks or actually not but that's why
they pay me some salary that's a big
question actually and you know that is
what keeps linguist and psychologist and
cognitive scientists employed because we
don't understand all the forces but the
short answer to that big question is we
have underlying cognitive and
articulatory pressures that constantly
affect us as speakers so an example of
that would be the fact that take a word
with a lot of consonants on it that's a
single syllable like whisks
which is you know word we use every day
when we're cooking and notice that when
you say it in fast speech or just really
any time you say it in speech you're
going to naturally just delete some of
the consonants off that so you'll say
you'll whisk it fast
um you're not going to say all the
whisks because it's a hard thing to say
or fifths that's another word sixths
those are all tricky words well the
reason you delete those consonants is
there's a natural inherent pressure a
cognitive preference we think for
languages to have very minimal syllable
structures and that means no consonants
at the end if possible some languages
actually prohibit all consonant
clustering but English allows a lot I
call it a promiscuous language for that
reason and so it's natural to delete
them that's sort of a cognitive trying
to get back to this cognitive preference
we have there's also some articulatory
issues so for example words like the are
words that begin with the that that
consonant cluster that sort of a th but
it's actually a single sound many many
languages don't have that sound so for
example my mother is a French speaker
and I used to make endless loads of fun
of her because she would say one two
Twee
because she couldn't make the th sound
right and she loved it of course that
was her favorite aspect of our
relationship I'm not sure but she
couldn't say that because it's not a
sound in French that also tells us that
it's either
articulatorily a disreferred sound or
cognitively a dispreferred sound so
languages will naturally if they have
that sound try to move towards not
having it anymore which is why a lot of
dialects of English say things like
Brava
ortif
because they're trying to get back to
that more natural consonant structure so
those are natural tendencies we have
that exist all the time pressure on us
all speakers all languages all the time
the part that I'm interested in is the
other pressure which is social pressure
so how is my social identity a factor in
which of those pressures I succumb to so
if I'm a female if I'm a young person if
I'm an African American if I'm a second
language speaker a non-native speaker
what do those pressures coupled with
those linguistic pressures create in
terms of dialects and it's because these
things swirl around us all the time
we're are always having these natural
pressures we're always something
socially we're always changing who we
are socially and that has a big impact
on which of those pressures that we
allow in our speech in which we don't
and in the end it's the cosmic language
change that results so language has
always had these pressures on it it
hasn't changed language might change but
the pressures don't we've always been
social right you know back in caveman
days I'm sure they did some social fun
stuff
um so you know it's always been there
and we just kind of interact and engage
and then that creates language change
over time obviously it's a lot more
complex but that's sort of the short
long answer
is it right in saying that languages
seem to change in a particular direction
towards Simplicity uh toward being more
straightforward easy to pronounce
okay that's a really a trick question
thinks the problem is a lot of times
when people think Simplicity they think
uh Simplicity in a cognitive sense and
that's really not what we're moving
towards and languages don't always get
simpler certain types of languages tend
to get less complex over time from a
standpoint of how they're articulated
and maybe how they're structured
morphosyntactically and those tend to be
large languages spoken by a lot of
speakers so like English for example or
Chinese or Russian they actually have a
lot of speakers a lot of non-native
speakers learn it a lot of adults that
may have to acquire it not perfectly and
that causes language to simplify over
time because the very complex Morpho
syntactic and phonological patterns that
babies are born into and able to acquire
because of their greater cognitive
plasticity does not exist in that case
as widely and therefore over time the
rules that are less transparent to pick
up atrophy and that is what causes sort
of a less complex structure sure I
wouldn't call it simpler but less
complex so English for example was
really complex in its early days it had
a lot of endings on all words so nouns
and verbs and pronouns so for example
think about how we say I do he does
right where you have that little s that
comes on well imagine that we had to do
that every time we used a noun an
adjective or a verb to make sure it fit
with all the other words in the Senate
so like German today has first of all it
has grammatical gender which means that
if I have a noun like the moon or the
sun I have to know whether it goes with
other male or female things depending on
which grammatical gender it belonged to
so that was one ending and that had to
stick on not just the nouns but the
adjectives there were several verb
classes in Old English so there were
strong classes and weak classes so all
the Ed verbs that we use today are weak
class verbs so they were a few a very
sort of minority class in Old English
the majority were the things like the
sing-sang song or drive driven kind of
class where they had these extra endings
that you put on and those weird
irregular verbs that we have in English
like
um I drive he drove I have driven that's
actually a holdout from the strong
classes of Old English now they're the
minority today and we just memorized
them but back then they were a regular
rule
so another fun example is is the plural
s we have just one ending to make
plurals in English super simple you want
to make something plural stick an s on
it you want to make a new word plural
stick an s on it but in Old English s
was actually the minority way of forming
plurals and it wasn't just an S it was
an as typically and many many other
forms of plurals existed and the reason
we have words like oxen and children is
because their holdouts from Old English
plurals that were much more frequent and
in fact shoes and eyes used to be
shoeing and iron back in the day so so
these are examples of complexity
um that that we lost over time I think
the trick is we think of simpler as
being sort of stupider or primitive and
that's actually false in the way of
language and a perfect example is you
know no one thinks English is a stupid
language and in fact we've created all
sorts of things we've made airplanes fly
we've created incredible life-saving
vaccines you know we've created the
internet
in English we do all of these things in
English so if we're really getting
simpler that probably wouldn't have
happened we'd be back in the days of
Beowulf which no one wants no one wants
to go back to that okay so you have a
pressure which is on language especially
languages that are widely used and
popular ones that need to be adopted by
people perhaps later in life because
they are the cognitive limitations that
you have just being an older person
trying to learn a language as opposed to
a child
right when it comes to language
acquisition that's just there we are so
because of that you inevitably
um
de-complexify you you reduce down the
complexity uh and that causes some of
the quirks some of the sticky Audi bits
that maybe are less logical to be eroded
away we end up therefore with a less
complex uh end result but that can't be
the same for every language and also
why if that's the case that languages
are on average especially when they're
widely used trending toward the less
complex
why are they complex to begin with why
not just make it simple from the start
well okay so these are a couple
different questions in there I think
that you've packed in one thing just
just to say is language
over time A lot of times through
language contact they get more complex
so it's this constant battle between
what's good for us as language speakers
which is to make it easier to
communicate in the most efficient way
possible which tends to lead to slightly
simpler less complex structures versus
the need to sort of have all the aspects
there to form the different things we
want to do with language which is
complex in in its own right so they're
they're constant pressures a lot of
times more complexity happens when
languages come in contact so we actually
acquire new things on top of the things
we already had but I I think one thing
to be careful of is when we're talking
about complexity here we're talking
about Morpho syntactic or phonological
complexity which just means we have a
lot of stuff put on words
um there's different types of complexity
you can gain so while English lost
morphosyntactic complexity meaning all
those endings fell off because who needs
them right we gained uh sort of lexical
or um you know uh what what would be
good pragmatic complexity meaning for
example our word order became more fixed
so it used to be in Old English you
could kind of be willy-nilly in what you
stuck at where because there were little
endings on all the words that told you
oh yeah this adjective goes with that
noun over there right they're friends so
you know you don't have to put them
together because they know they're
friends but we lose those things over
time and then we don't know they're
friends anymore if we're sticking the
adjective at the end of the sentence and
the noun it modifies at the beginning so
as you lose the endings that tell you
you work you're together like the
wedding rings are gone so we no longer
they're no they're together then we have
to do other things that make up for it
so what English did instead is get a
more fixed word order so now our
adjectives go before our nouns right and
our subjects go before our verbs and our
objects go after that and so that allows
anybody listening to an English sentence
to know okay it's first so it has to be
the subject oh it's last so it has to be
the object we didn't have to do that
back then so it's a different kind of
complexity so I I do want to be careful
and so we're not saying that
everything's simplifying but what
happens over time
is generally that smaller languages that
had very few speakers which was the
origin of all language I mean back in
the day if we go back you know 50 000
years when we think language first
started it wasn't thousands and
thousands and millions of people that
spoke them it was very small groups and
they could transmit that kind of
complexity
um and so what happens is when you move
away from small groups and you get to
millions of speakers the original
purpose of language which was sort of to
allow Communication in a small group has
changed and then language changes with
it so we're talking about evolutionary
processes and that's really what has
caused languages to change and when you
look at indigenous languages for example
um those you know austronesian languages
or Native American languages that have
very few speakers often in the hundreds
those languages tend to be much more
complex than languages like English
Chinese or Russian and that's because
their purpose is to communicate in a
small group and therefore for they don't
need to simplify over time because
they're not having this transmission
across large swaths of speakers and and
when we transmit and when I'm saying
things change over time I'm not saying
all of a sudden someone wakes up and
it's like okay who needs that Morpho
syntax let's just get rid of those
stupid endings I feel like saying eyes
instead of I in today that's not what
happens it's transmission to children so
when you get larger groups of speakers
then the rules become more opaque to the
adults and they transp transmit those
sort of inconsistencies to their
children who then acquired this sort of
simpler Morpho syntax oh so
um mofo syntaxes die one generation at a
time in that way all language change
works that way that it been basically
old people don't pick up new tricks
we're kind of like old dogs we just
don't do it now certain superficial
things like a vocabulary word you know I
can learn to twerk
um but that doesn't mean I should that
definitely doesn't mean I should
but I it's a lot harder for me to learn
something like
um front vowel tense and laxness which
we have in New York whether you hear
like
versus some words like glass wouldn't be
La would be tense and some would be less
so this is really kind of tricky and
it's a very very very complex rule where
you you tense the a vowel before
so-called fricatives which are sounds
like s or F so it'd be laugh but cat so
you'd hear the slight difference that's
something that's really hard to transmit
to any speaker learning English or even
an English speaker that moves to New
York as a 15 year old is not going to
get that very complex sort of types of
pattern in there so I think what we need
to think about is sort of when we're
talking about language change what
general people think about as language
changes like a new word I've picked up
but what linguists think about is
language change is a new sound system I
picked up new vowels I've picked up new
new Morpho syntax so new endings on my
words new pronouns which of course were
all upset about picking up these days
but that has happened through history
we've had a bunch of different pronouns
and in fact most of the pronouns we have
today like she and they didn't even
exist at the beginning of English so
they have both come into English since
the middle English period uh therefore
we obviously have changed our pronouns a
few times I've been around the block on
that front as well
what about um and uh because these seem
like words that are not only very common
in English depending on who you're
speaking to but I speak to friends who
are native speakers of a different
language who make ums and Earth sounds
in different it's a different sound even
when they're trying to speak English to
me so that seems like a human Universal
it is actually I'm in our fascinating
and you know you call them words but
there's actually a huge debate in
linguistic circles uh you know this is
what we do late at night about whether
they are in fact words or not uh they
they sort of act like um utterances that
things that sort of just come out that
aren't necessarily governed by the same
rules that words are but we also find
them written in things where it's like
um no and so that suggests a more word
like employment so you know there's kind
of a debate over the whether we'd call
them words but regardless of what we
call them filled pauses which is what
those are are things that are Universal
they've been found in every language
study they do differ slightly so some
languages will have a lot more than two
some languages only have two but
basically all languages have at least
two and most proto-indo-european
languages have something along the form
of uh or um and usually they differ by
the vowel why that sound what is it
that's about the
physiology of the mouth perhaps the way
that the brain tries to make sounds come
out what is it that's causing so many
different languages to zero in on
um or ER or something similar right well
there are a lot of different answers to
that depending on which aspect you're
trying to answer but just for the sound
itself actually it's a really
interesting question because if we look
at most languages most of them have sort
of a vowel like filled pause like uh
that we write with a uh but it's just a
vowel you know like someone punches you
in the gut you just go right and then we
have one with a nasal sound and nasal
sounds are things like ends or M's and
so English has um but so for example in
Japanese you have ano which also has a
nasal sound so we find some syllables
that's interesting yes well some
languages like Chinese and Japanese
actually use demonstrative pronouns as
filled pauses so it can be a range of
things and in in Spanish esta is a
filled pause so there that also is
something that functions as a word in
other cases but is brought in as a
filled pause so sometimes languages do
that where they use another pre-existing
word other languages mostly Germanic
languages use uh and on because that
seems to have inherited from a
proto-language so we suspect that since
English is very similar to German and
other languages like Finnish and um yeah
Danish and Swedish they all have these
similar uh um types of sounds that they
probably were inherited from
proto-germanic which may even have been
inherited from proto-indo-european so
they're very old
but the reason we probably do that sound
is if you'd say the uh sound just say uh
uh all right so your mouth is kind of
just at rest right so if you didn't do
much with your mouth and someone punch
you in the gut that's the sound you
would make so it's an easy kind of just
simple sound and it's Central to the
mouth so you're not moving to get to
different targets like you are in speech
sounds it's just what is emanated sort
of as your brain is thinking um so
that's probably why that sound in
English was inherited the um is
interesting because
one of the reasons we think that sound
might be used more than uh or have
developed is partially because from a
sound symbolism standpoint it's a more
polite sound so if you go ah you know
it's kind of ugly your mouth's hanging
open a fly can just wander in there but
if you say
um it's it's much more pleasant isn't it
it's the formal of uh exactly you gotta
have synonyms for everything right but
actually they're really interesting
about uh and um is they do different
work for us so both of them are
basically speech planners so as we're
thinking of more complex things to say
of harder vocabulary less familiar terms
or really long syntactic structures they
tend to come out but uh signals to a
listener that you're going to just take
a really quick delay I'm I'm thinking
about it's coming out in just a second
but when you um it actually tends to
precede longer delays which means that
we're actually pretty intentional about
which one we're using we don't have
synonyms typically that don't develop
different meanings so you know it's not
there's really no point in doing the
exact same thing so language just
automatically tries to give different
meanings to them so us seems to signal I
need a short delay um seems to Signal
it's going to take me a little longer to
figure this out
why would people choose to use this I
understand that it's a sound but is this
uh mental cognitive processing is this
our buffering screen is this something
else what's going on yeah you know how
the internet has that little twirly
thing that's basically what I mean uh
are and have you noticed that you know
when you're really in a hurry and you're
trying to do something complex it tends
to give you that little twirly signal
more same thing with um and uh they tend
to occur when we're doing more difficult
cognitive processing so you know the
idea that I'm an R sort of signals that
we don't know what we're saying or we're
uncertain or hesitant are not true in
the sense that they signal that we don't
know what we're talking about in fact
what they signal is that we're doing a
lot of work to say the right thing or to
come up with the right word but it does
signal that we're doing cognitive work
and that our processing is is going so
it's basically a sort of signal of brain
churning but what we find is that it's
not just brain turning if we're doing
Simple tasks the more we uh and um the
more likely it is that we're actually
doing harder things like coming up with
words we don't use very often coming up
with more technical vocabulary or coming
up with a more complex embedded sentence
structure so morphosyntactically more
complex so we tend to correlate our uh
and um use with how difficult the thing
we're doing is which is probably why we
um and uh more when we're in context
that require you know higher more
pollutant sorts of speech like in the
workplace or at school that kind of
thing where we want to impress people so
we're trying to come up with those big
vocabulary words rather than you know
twerk
how does
this how how is this interpreted by
other people so
from our side let's say that it is a
byproduct of this cognitively demanding
High Ram 64 gigabyte required processing
speed that we're going through
that should be the case if it's true
that other people should always
interpret ums and URS as signals of
authenticity
um somebody that is working incredibly
hard to get their sentence across I
really should pay more attention yet
ums and does aren't exactly valorized as
this fantastic introduction into
somebody's speech pattern right so this
is one of those really interesting
places where things that offer us
linguistic benefits which I'm really
really do they're actually very
beneficial to us as both speakers and
listeners they don't match up with
social benefits because they don't
really offer social benefits on you know
on the whole people don't really like uh
and um and in fact they often think it
signals someone doesn't know what
they're talking about or they're
hesitant or uncertain so if you go
listen to someone give a presentation
and their eye and numbing their way
through it you're probably going to sort
of shut down or stop listening or you'll
say to your friends oh my God if that
person says no another I'm just going to
kill me and when people overdo it we
really really notice them so they're not
really considered great speech features
but that's kind of funny because they're
actually pretty great speech features if
we look at them from a linguistic and
cognitive standpoint part of the problem
is in the context that we notice
people's humming and eyeing which is
usually presentations or speeches is
those are contexts we expect people to
have practice to have rehearsed to know
what they're going to say and since we
know that on Signal someone's sort of
thinking through things I think part of
the reason we dislike them in those
contexts is because they signal to us
that someone hasn't done their homework
so if someone's giving a presentation
then they're eyeing and numbing their
way through it I'm thinking God did you
not read this before you came up here
and you know bored me one thing that we
do notice is when people are more
Dynamic speakers when they say something
that's more interesting and they're more
engaging people actually don't tend to
note their O's and ums as much as people
that give sort of a monotonous sort of
boring delivery and maybe don't have
content that's really interesting so a
lot depends on what you're saying
but also the practice issue I think in
places where we expect someone to have
rehearsed and know their content signals
that we're working through it is not a
great thing to have on the flip side
though when we look at the research on
what an um do for us they both help us
as a speaker with speech planning they
signal to the listener that my turn is
not done and how long a delay to expect
so those are both beneficial things but
even more so for listeners if we look at
studies that do either eye tracking or
event related potential studies things
that sort of are measures of cognitive
processing on the listeners part they
actually seem to help us have faster
recognition of what someone's going to
say be able to better predict what
someone's going to say are better at new
information processing and remember
things better later so that's not bad
for a little filled pause
wow so we have a bunch of different
Dynamics crashing up against each other
here one is the buffering requirement or
the advantage that using these filler
words
offer us another is that it
is potentially useful at helping the
people that we are speaking to both
retain and understand what it is that
we're saying but all of this gets
filtered through these social
expectation which disincentivizes both
the speaker and The Listener from this
happening so that's very it's very
interesting the fact that this is good
for you as a listener but might not be
what you want to hear as a listener
right but if you look at language over
time anyway most of the things that we
think of as bad speech are actually not
bad at all it's just sort of social
historical accident that we don't like
them so a lot of things so think about
like use you know the way that people
say like all the time people hate that I
I hear nothing but bad things about like
if I go give a talk it can be on a
completely different topic and then
afterwards people will come up and say
oh my God I love your talk tell people
to stop saying like all the time if only
I had that power right uh and I wouldn't
want it because actually like is very
beneficial so that's another example of
we're doing something to help fill a
void that we need in our language or to
help us do a function or a purpose that
we haven't found to be met by other
things in our language and yet because
they're not the right speakers that do
them or because we take them to Signal
something else we socially interpret
them negatively so with an um I think
it's because a lot of times we do
associate them with hesitancy or
uncertainty and it's true they do signal
the fact that someone is working through
things but is that a bad thing you know
why do we think that's bad that someone
is working through what they're going to
tell us I don't want someone to just
spout off you know incoherent stuff
because they're not thinking it through
if you step back to consider why we uh
and um it's actually for pretty good
reasons it's just that we don't like it
because it signals to us someone isn't
sure what the what they're saying and
maybe they haven't practiced enough
what about the difference between using
um and uh versus just having silence
you know that's an interesting question
and certainly it's been studied so in
some of the research that looked at the
gay game that listeners Get By Hearing
an uh and or an um before a word in in a
series of sentences they would also do
those same experiments where they had a
silent pause instead of inserting an uh
or on before the word to see if maybe it
was simply that people have more time to
think and that's why they do better at
comprehension and what they found is a
silent pause didn't have the same effect
nor did something like a cough that also
gave the same amount of time but was a
different kind of distractor and in fact
things like costs actually hindered
comprehension so clearly we are treating
uh and um differently than both other
distractors and Silent pauses from a
cognitive standpoint So Silent pauses
don't give us the bum that uh seems to
give us on the flip side silent pauses
are sometimes better in a context like
giving a presentation so I'm not telling
people go stick uh and um into your
presentation Because unless I've talked
to that audience before you get there it
probably will still not be taken as
great speaking but especially at the
beginning of a sentence because we do
find that people either uh or um at the
beginning of the sentence depending on
how long they think it's going to take
them to answer the question so it does
seem to be taken as a marker of
uncertainty particularly at the very
beginning of the sentence so that might
be one to stay away from but when we
again do studies that look at how people
take silent pauses versus fill pauses
in some cases they can take silent
pauses as greater signal signals of
anxiety than when someone filled their
paws with uh or um probably because they
weren't sure when someone paused in that
context whether they were just not sure
what they were going to say or whether
they forgot what they were going to say
it doesn't give the listener the same
clue that you know you're working on it
instead it might lead to some
misconception when you silently pause
that either you haven't finished but you
don't know what you're going to say or
you suddenly abruptly did finish and
it's someone else's turn so it can be a
little more confusing whereas uh and um
are signals to a listener specifically
I'm working on it I'm going to keep
talking so while silent pause is
certainly in speeches are sometimes very
effective especially when you want to
add power to what you're saying so you
give people a moment to think about it
it's not always beneficial in casual
conversation to do that
I have a friend who does a lot of
debates and he uses uh turn transition
cues in a similar way to what you're
talking about but he doesn't use Omar
and he learned this from Christopher
Hitchens so he's having a debate with
somebody and one of the things that he's
conscious of is that if he gets anywhere
close to a pause Point within his
sentence the other person is potentially
going to jump in and then try and make a
point so what he does is he'll start the
beginning of a sentence like that take a
sip of water give himself the breathing
room to go through things and then keep
going because you're no one's going to
jump in after the are you kidding me
that's so rude but right if he started
it before the beginning of the sentence
or halfway through at a point that
seemed like a more natural break it
allows somebody to come in so yeah I
understand that
ums and URS are a nice foam finger that
you can wave in the air that says I I
got a little bit more to talk about here
just hang fire one second mate I know
that I might not get the next word out
immediately but just I require a bit
more don't jump in here right it's sort
of like hey dude I'm still talking kind
of signal but that's exactly right in
turn transition cues I'm impressed
that's a big linguistic term and it
basically to just is anytime we're
indicating to someone that it's their
turn and that can be something that we
do spoken like uh saying you know stop
talking and just have silence or we can
select somebody so I can say Chris what
do you think and that is definitely a
term transition cue I can even just look
at people but it's very because there's
so many of them and they do different
work in terms of how people interpret
them it can be very confusing when
someone just stops talking or doesn't
use some sort of signal that they're
either not done or they are done so on
are a great solution for that and they
do seem to work that way
I know that you're coming at this from a
linguistic perspective but I I would be
stupid of me not to bring this up with
you no one on the podcast that's ever
listening to this is ever going to see
the volume of nods that I put in while
the guest is speaking so as I'm here I'm
just going away like a little nodding
dog sat on the back of a car that has to
be kind of
not quite like a turn transition cue but
it's like an encouragement so what I'm
doing while I'm here is yeah that's good
keep on going keep on going that's good
yeah enjoying it enjoying it and then if
I need to take if I stop it's going oh
maybe he's got something to say so this
is a silent equivalent of a
whatever the whatever the opposite of a
turn transition keep my turn transition
cue
a lot of times we do it when we say
things like aha yeah right which of
course we try not to do on a podcast
because you can talk over the other
person first ever episode was filled
with um
[Music]
it took a long time for me to deprogram
it and the the person that I picked up
the nodding thing from was Oprah oh
that's a perfect person to take cues
from and you know it's funny because
actually it signals that you're more
conscientious nicer listener turn
transition I mean that back channels are
actually a very lovely thing to do
that's it's conversational support
you're encouraging someone to keep going
you're showing listenership it has all
those sort of of aspects to it but when
you do things like interview guests or I
have learned not to back Channel too
much because I do a lot of
sociolinguistic interviewing and the
last thing you can do is analyze
someone's speech when you're talking
over their speech with uh haha yeah
great wow so you just sort of learned
not to do it but in casual conversation
it's weird if you don't and in fact
there have been some really interesting
studies about how people take uh people
that don't back Channel very much or
what how they misread their intentions
um a famous study of course was done
between men and women with the idea that
men tend to not use back channeling as
much as women which is why women think
men are [__] I mean I'm sure there's
other reasons that
there has been some in some there were
there were some studies one uh I'm
thinking about was done in the 80s by
Pamela Fishman uh who did some research
on conversational discourse and she
found among couples that men tended to
not back Channel
um or did a delayed back channeling
which is worse which is where you don't
do it in time so you know there's very
normal places to insert that uh-huh yeah
uh-huh that shows excitement and like
you're right there and you're keeping up
with them you're listening and you know
yes keep going and then there's the
yeah
uh-huh that really slow kind of three
seconds too late that means I'm not I'm
reading the newspaper I'm not even
paying attention so what she found was
men used more delayed back channels than
women did
I think you know it's changed I haven't
read any recent studies of that um
hopefully it has changed I think a lot
of things have changed at that time and
we don't find it quite as distributed by
male and female anymore and it certainly
can be personality type you know there
are people that are really Avid engaged
listeners more conscientious listeners
and you can do psychological tests to
test out those people and there was a
really interesting study on discourse
markers and those are things like you
know well so
um and we found that more conscientious
people it wasn't my study but it was
found that more conscientious people
tend to use more of those as well so I
think it also is by personality type and
it's probably by socio-cultural
background as well but yes there was
there was a gender difference initially
in back channeling okay what about the
word like why does anybody use it
oh I love like I mean what's not to love
about like
uh you know a lot of people hate that
word uh they hate it in except for the
verb you know where they like
ice cream for example but the like
that's used as a discourse marker are a
quotative verb so those would be things
such as I'm gonna have to watch my like
use here uh like he goes to school like
you know or and that sort of discourse
marker like that's overdone but that's
an example or a quotative like would be
something where you use it instead of
the verb to say so if you're talking
about a party and you're talking about
what John said you might say well John
was like I don't think I'm going to go
tomorrow and I was like I think you
should right that's a quotative verb so
those are very different likes and in
fact there are at least three if not
more different very legitimate uses of
like that are not the traditional uses
of like which would be like as a verb
like as a noun or like as a preposition
so in a simile construction for example
the ones that are less accepted are like
as a conjunction so if you say something
like I feel like or it seems like or he
pretends like those types of likes even
though we all use those are actually
frowned upon by the grammar events but
the newest forms that we really dislike
are those discourse marker likes that
sort of dot to our linguistic Landscapes
when we're saying things but if you
think about where they show up and it's
not random or chaotic despite what
people might believe they actually tend
to show up when a speaker is trying to
do some sort of subjective approximation
an estimation or apply the sort of
imprecisis of meaning so that their
listener gets that sense that this is
their own evaluation of a situation so
if I said like he was a lawyer or
something that means I'm telling you
this is my own opinion I don't really
know for sure but I'm estimating or
approximating what I think he was or
she's like popular or something means
it's not quite that that's not the exact
fit that's not exactly how I describe it
but that's the best I can do because
there's not really words available to
describe my meaning so those are
actually very valuable because what
they're communicating to you as a
listener is I'm not making any strong
claims about this is exactly how the
world is I'm telling you this is my
perception of how the world is in this
case or it can intensify or emphasize
something so if I said I ran like 20
miles today well you know I didn't run
20 miles I don't look that exhausted or
that fit
[Laughter]
but what I'm saying is I ran a lot I'm
emphasizing just for effect how much so
in all those cases whether I'm using it
as a quotative verb which then tells you
I'm not verbatim quoting what someone
says we're sort of estimating what they
said or if I'm telling you an estimate
of how much I ran for emphasis they're
actually serving a really useful purpose
it's simply that age-wise older speakers
tend not to use them
they use about instead or they use you
know as a discourse marker instead or
some sort of other discourse marker
younger speakers people under 40 tend to
use like a lot more and so that's where
we really see a generational divide and
how acceptable people find it when did
it get introduced
well for you know the popular belief
you'd say the valley girls in the 1980s
with I think was Moon Unit Zappa who
sang that fabulous song valley girl you
know where she liked and gagged me with
a spoon all over the place but that was
actually just picking up on an
undercurrent of something that was
already in Southern California's speech
at the time and in fact and Chris you're
gonna like this like is a British
feature and we find it traces back
centuries in British speech and if you
look at old Criminal Court transcripts
from the 1700s the old bailing
proceedings which are great documents
for linguists to look at how colloquial
speech was back in the day when before
we had cell phones and smartphones to
record everything and we find that like
actually occurred as a discourse marker
as back as far back as the 1700s so it's
been around a long time and I'm afraid
we have to blame the Brits for this one
okay I've got a I've got a little video
that I wanted to show you and see if
this can work can you see that I
I think like the biggest like annoys me
the whole dating world is like [__]
talking stages like that shit's so
annoying like the whole like
and just like the inconsistency in them
like I literally like hate that like so
much but I think that's like my biggest
thing is just like what specifically
just like the fact of just like you like
I don't know how to word this
like in like talking stages and it's
just like you're like labeled that and
it's like people like are considered
like you can't like you're just like
confused and like most of the time like
the girl gets like gets like attached or
something and they like see it like it's
gonna lead to a relationship and it's
always not and it's just like
that's like my biggest thing is like I
just hate the whole like how like
talking stages are so like normalized
like traditional dating does not exist
in this generation
so that was 27 likes in 48 seconds there
all right and you know when you draw
attention to it it really stands out
right so the fact that we're talking
about like it definitely stands out a
couple of things I would say is that's
obviously a young woman and that's tends
to be who we we sort of dis in terms of
like use more than young men although
actually studies don't show that there's
really a significant difference
generally between young men and young
women older men and women there is some
difference but generally speaking it's a
young feature and what we find with like
is if we look at how it distributes over
a lifespan younger speakers tend to like
at a much higher degree than they will
as the same speaker 10 years later so
part of that is the stage of life she's
in but notice when she was talking it's
all estimation she's giving her own
Impressions her own opinions her own
sort of uh approximation of what she
likes what she doesn't of her opinion
and so for example
um she was saying I hate when it's like
I can't even remember what she was
saying truthfully but uh you know she
was talking about how how she feels when
things happen and so this is a perfect
example of why like was so prevalent in
Her speech because almost every instance
she's talking about something that is
her own subjective sensibility now was
it excessive certainly but a lot of
times when we look at young speech we
find a overuse of something and that's
called age grading which atrophies as
they get older because it's sort of cool
and they're set to talk that way it's
part of just sort of learning to use
that feature and it's a novel feature
coming in so it gets overused
then as they go into the Working World
and people frown upon them as the you
know one million people probably wrote
nasty comments under that
you tend to lower your use especially in
settings where you would be expected not
to use them so for every parent out
there who's freaking out about how their
daughter or son uses like all the time
in that context don't worry I promise
they're still employable despite what
you might think what is the social uh
interpretation of the use of the word
like
well I think it depends on the age group
among younger speakers so I think when
that young woman was talking to other
young women it's not noticed at all I
have a teenage daughter and she uses
like quite a bit and when she has her
friends on the way to volleyball in the
back of the car it is a like Fest I hear
a lot I hear a lot there's a lot of
low-key there's a lot of slay there's a
lot of like
but again that's in her own peer group
and that's very normal and it's kind of
I think part of the reason it's used a
lot is it gives this sort of young hip
kind of urban sort of sense and that's
very much what young women and young men
are trying to pull off when they're with
their friends
um so as she gets older I'm expecting
she won't use it but the social benefit
to her is it gives off that sort of
um cool hip not too concerned with you
know academics and scholasticness you
know it's sort of imprecision in a way
it's relaxed yeah you know kind of the
chill Vibe uh the sort of Southern
California chill Vibe and that's what I
think young women are going for on young
men it is also quite prevalent with
young men but I do know that people all
the time bring up just like that example
people that use it excessively and I
think the reason we notice and call
those out is because they are excessive
and unusual so I teach 20 somethings
every year and they're delightful and I
will tell you they're very concerned
about their like use I at the very first
day of class I said you know I'll say
what do you notice about speech just
tell me something
I don't say tell me something bad about
speech I just say tell me what you
notice every single year every single
class period like like like like I hate
like and they'll even say I hate like
how people use like all the time which
is then of course the rest of the class
we laugh every time that person uses
like because once you've noticed it it's
very very Salient but young people are
aware of it and they are self-conscious
about it my students are very
self-conscious about it so I make them
study it I make them analyze their
speech I have them have a conversation
and record where they use it and how
they use it which gives them two tools
it first lets them see that it's
purposeful most of the time people don't
use it as excessively as that example
and you use it in cases for example
where you're using it as a quotative
where you're using as approximate an
adverbial or you're using it as a
sentential adverbial so if you can put a
name to it it makes it seem a little
more like it has a function but the
other benefit is if they want to lower
their use and they know how they use it
you can take things to yourself okay
wait I know I use it as a approximating
adverbial I'm going to use about instead
so instead of saying I ran like 10 miles
you can just think to yourself I ran
about 10 miles and so if you give
someone the tools by understanding their
speech then they have tools to help
themselves whether they want to justify
its use or change it to you so I think
that's my approach to like right so
rather than feeling as if like is a
curse that gets thrown and Scattered
across a sentence and it's essentially
impossible for you to get rid of what
you're doing here is saying it's there
for a purpose here are three different
distinct purposes if you want to reduce
the usage of the word like one of the
things that you need to do is look at
where it gets brought in and then in
advance perhaps at the start of that
sentence just take an extra half beat
and think
I will use about I will use one of the
other replace Alternatives exactly
exactly as a sociolinguist I love like
you know I think it's a fascinating
thing to study and I love the fact that
it's actually much more powerful and
purposeful than people give it credit
for but as a person and as a mother I do
get the concern with women and men using
like and especially women because we
diss their speech so much that a man can
use a young man can use the same amount
of like and not be judged in the same
way and it can have professional
consequences at least we worry about
that so I want to give people the tools
to look at like either way and as long
as you realize there's nothing bad about
it there's nothing wrong with it but it
may not be professionally and socially
beneficial for you to do it and if
that's the case understanding it will
give you some tools as well
what's happening with vocal fry as well
speaking of dissing women's voices right
now this is vocal fries are really
interesting feature and for people that
don't understand what vocal fry is it's
that sort of crackly poppy sort of noise
that sometimes comes into particularly
women's voices as they get through the
end of the Senate so that would be
something like I don't know about that
where you can hear that kind of fry that
that crackliness come in we call it
Creek in linguistics we actually don't
refer to it as vocal fry we refer to it
as creaky voice which I think is way
more descriptive of what it sounds like
and actually what happens with Creek or
vocal fry is that you have the vocal
folds and I'm going to give you for
those of you that are looking you can
see that these are sort of your vocal
folds which are kind of these muscular
flaps at the top of the larynx so
usually we have them kind of pulled
tight and long and so you can either
open them a little to make a voiceless
sound where the air flows through freely
and that would be like a Tata sound or
you can close them and um push air
through and that makes them vibrate
as you do your pitch too you push them
through the vocal folds and the
vibration of the vocal folds is what
determines your average pitch so in
normal cases just your everyday average
pitch the thing we recognize when we
talk to our our husbands or our wives or
when someone we know calls us on the
phone that's just normal phonation it's
called that's just a certain vibration
of the vocal folds but when we get into
creaky voice what happens is we take
those same vocal folds and we kind of
bunch them up so they're thicker do you
see how they can kind of get thicker and
think of a rubber band if you have a
rubber band and it's pulled really tight
and you ping it it's going to well if it
doesn't snap you and you go [__] that
really hurt if it stays together it's
going to vibrate at a very regular rate
but if you kind of let it fall and get
soft and you kind of ping it it's just
going to be like right it's not gonna
really do much it's not going to be a
regular vibration well when you Bunch
your vocal folds up and you make them
thicker and heavier they vibrate at a
slower rate because they're heavier and
they tend to vibrate irregularly now
lower pitch in general is just a slower
vibe vibration of vocal folds if you add
on top of that in a regular vibration
that's when you get creaky voice and so
it happens at a low pitch
what happens is we actually find that
men do it too but because men operate at
a lower pitch more generally that drop
in Pitch to Make local fry is not as
obvious so when we notice women doing it
it's because they go from a higher pitch
at the front end of their sentence to a
much lower pitch to enact vocal fry what
we find is women have been doing it in
professional settings particularly so
one of the biggest complaints you hear
is in radio shows or broadcasting where
people have women's voices so NPR is an
area where people have complained in
fact there was a show This American Life
that was completely dedicated one of the
episodes to vocal fry and how many
haters wrote in because of the women on
that show the broadcasters the
journalists that actually had vocal
frying their voices what we find is
early studies in the 1990s and the early
2000s showed that women in broadcasting
settings actually local fried more than
men in those settings and more than
women elsewhere which suggests that
they're actually responding to that
pressure for women in broadcasting to
have lower pitch voices which is
something that they've had a pressure on
them since the 1950s I mean I think
Barbara Walters spoke a lot about the
fact that as a woman broadcasting she
was expected to put a certain voice on
there have been lots of complaints by
women saying that their low voice their
High voices were called shrill and
unacceptable on the airwaves well what's
the solution throw in a little low pitch
vocal fry and why don't you do lower
pitch just in general well because women
get the double bind of being less
attractive in terms of ratings that
people give them when we hear them with
a lower pitch voice so women with
high-pitched voices are more attractive
but not very professional or competent
man with low pitch voice are both
professional competent and attractive so
women have this double bind in a
workplace where they have to adopt a
lower pitch voice to be taken seriously
but then their judge is less attractive
so what if you have a high voice with a
little vocal fry
that gives you a little bit of two birds
with one stone right where you get this
attractive rating with the higher pitch
voice it's your more normal voice you
have a little vocal fry on the end to
kind of get that more professional Urban
feel which is really how women hear that
that feature and that kills the problem
of being not attractive but professional
or being not professional but attractive
so it's kind of a really cool solution I
think not well loved yeah what you're
saying there is other women seem to
interpret vocal fry more positively than
men do is that right well I think Young
is the Judgment of older speakers
particularly ones that would listen to
NPR you know not many of my 20 year old
males listen to NPR in my class nor my
females
um not all of them I'm sure there are
some but they tend to listen to a little
different kind of more you know hip
stuff so you know when you get to be
older an older speaker you have these
ideas and Norms in your head and you
might be more judgmental but young women
hear vocal fry as Urban as professional
as sort of chill and relaxed as intimate
so we find positive attributes with
vocal fry among younger speakers and
those don't seem to translate so much to
older speakers and part of it's also
just the fact that we diss women's
voices in professional context so when
women do it and we notice it it's a bad
thing but if you look at longer term
research on vocal fry in British
speakers which is where it was first
studied
British Men actually use vocal fry at a
rate of three to ten times more than
British women so you know it it wasn't
considered an epidemic or sort of a a
vocal um pandemic until women in America
started doing it at much higher rate but
in Britain even today it's still men
that fry more
are you familiar with David putz do you
know him evolutionary psychologist yes I
do I know he has done a lot of research
on voice and evolutionary series of
voice correct yeah so he was on the show
a little while ago and he was telling me
I think his master's thesis perhaps or
his his PhD was done on vocal pitch and
he was looking at it uses This brilliant
example from when he was at Uni doing
his undergrad and apparently he was
stood in a checkout queue and there was
a couple of guys behind him and he heard
how low both of their voices were and
couldn't believe it he thought he's
going to turn around and see these man
mountains or a guy with a Siamese twin
that's got a second neck like it's
impossible to have such a low voice and
he turned around and it was just two
normal dudes but stood in between him
and the normal dudes was a pretty hot
girl I was gonna say I'm sure there was
a hot woman somewhere in this in this
right yeah right you know um
interpretations of both Prestige and
dominance like lower vocal pitch is
associated with longer and bigger vocal
folds which is associated with being a
bigger animal over time that's the same
reason that before animals tried to
fight they're actually going to growl or
make Roars at each other this is how big
you don't want to fight me look at the
amount of sound that I can make if you
can hear the amount of sound you don't
want to come near these hands bro so
yeah I'm going to bang my chest while I
make low guttural noises kind of
precisely yeah I actually saw a gorilla
do that a Silverback Gorilla did that
five yards away from me in the windy
impenetrable forest in Uganda and that
was um not too much it was just a little
reminder like that he wasn't happy that
we were lurking around him
um so one of the trying to tie together
a bunch of the different trends that
we're seeing at the moment it seems like
we're leaning towards
um
less formal language it seems to be like
going toward an informal style of
languages is something that's happening
at the moment
how much has social media contributed to
the changes that we've seen in language
and given the fact that probably for the
first time ever we have a higher
proportion of people communicating with
each other non-verbally probably ever
ever in history ever have you considered
how this and the introduction of social
media and its propagation and mass use
has changed the way that people relate
to each other linguistically
well you know that's a pretty new thing
social media of course there have been
studies on more uh sort of traditional
forms of media so television for example
and radio uh and sort of to look at how
that affects speech and certainly I
think the last few years the last
several decades not only has social
media opened up the world but
transportation networks I mean you don't
there really are no very few
undiscovered parts and that you can't
just go on vacation and hang out right
so it's really changed massively our
communication networks and how we we
talk to each other so you know there
have been some studies I know the ones
on television use about how that spreads
changes what we tend to find is um
television is one of those things and
social media is the same thing is it
doesn't have natural social engagement
in the way that everyday conversation
does and so if you stick a baby in front
of you know Tick Tock or if you stick a
baby in front of Tom Brokaw you know or
some sort of television show they're not
going to learn language from that not
because they're not hearing it but
because they're not having engagement
from it and what we find with language
is it's social engagement in an
authentic kind of space that really
leads to both child language acquisition
being optimal and adult transmission of
changes so most of the things we see on
social media or most of the things that
we see in the world on you know on
television are things that are already
there at some low level so they're
already in the community television
social media doesn't invent anything but
what it does is disseminates it so once
it gets in a place where it's done by
someone who has some sort of quality or
some sort of emotional resonance with
people
and they do something cool with their
language whether it's something they're
aware of or not then if I see it on
social media and I'm sort of young and
influential and sort of influenced
easily or even if I'm old and influenced
easily or they have some quality that I
want to embody it's a very natural thing
to kind of move towards that speech
style or move towards that word or move
towards the way that they they
physically move or the way they dress
and of course language operates the same
so I would say that the impact social
media has is one on of dissemination not
Innovation so no one is doing things on
social media and starting a trend in
terms of language change but what
they're doing is they're disseminating
changes that were in their communities
so a good example and this is a really
superficial one but a good example is
the word Riz I don't know if you've
heard that word so if you have maximum
RIS it means you're kind of you're
really sexy with the ladies
um generally it was started by a young
African-American male so it's usually
used by men and it became the tick talk
storm in fact I know it because my kids
were both joking about who has maximum
risk in their high school and that just
means you know you can just like look at
serious rizz is when you just look at
someone you know with this sort of
Zoolander gaze and they come running to
you and in fact there were all sorts of
tick tock memes where uh boys would go
in front of the attack track team and be
like giving them the eyeball and then of
sort all these track women start running
towards them because he's at the Finish
Line not because he actually had Riz but
that you know it's kind of became a joke
well that went viral and not in the
community where it started which was
sort of the hip-hop African-American
kind of genre but because that embodies
something that a lot of young men and
want to emulate a lot of young white men
love to talk with a hip hop kind of
vocabulary so they pick up words like
that to take those qualities of sort of
machismo and toughness which are
actually stereotypes about the people
that use it not really why they use
those features but those are the
stereotypes that young white men have
about young African-American men that
they're tough and they're physically
they sort of have a lot of physicality
and they're hot with the ladies and
therefore we take those stereotypes we
see those features that embody it and
then we pick them up and that is the
power of social media and it certainly
has been very influential in that I
think the question you asked about
informal language use is not something
that social media has inspired that's
been a tendency in our language over
time
and if you think about the 18th and 19th
century who wants that kind of formality
I mean it was the height of formality
where you know you had to wear like 50
layers and you had to use these very
very extravagant politeness routines and
it took you forever to just get a coffee
at Starbucks I mean it was a real pain
in the ass who needs that so what we've
done is we've become more efficient I
think in our communication and what has
changed is not our language but our
culture and our culture has become more
informal and language follows culture
not the other way around and just like
our forms of trust have become less
formal
um you know so if you look at most
workplaces people don't wear three-piece
suits anymore I'm not happy workplaces
at least but no one is saying okay my
God the downfall of man has happened
because we're not wearing really
uncomfortable suits and ties and I think
we have to look at language that way as
well there's nothing wrong with being
less formal in our language and really
formality in language is a relative
cultural belief if you look back to Old
English the Anglo-Saxons were not the
height of fashion or formality so you
know more blood feuds and killing so I'm
sure they weren't saying sir kind sir
would you whine shall we do this I mean
they didn't say that kind of stuff so
they were very informal in their speech
in fact you didn't ask someone to do
something you told them to do it you
shout do X was how you would say it not
would you mind please kind sir do X so
that kind of really fancy formality is
really something that was an early
modern and early early True Modern
period so it's really not that the you
know death of modern decorum it simply
we've changed to be a more formal
society and language is changing with us
and still when we go to formal cases
formal places and give speeches or go to
workplaces we we know how to ramp it up
and be dressed up in our speech so
anybody who's worried about that I think
you can rest easy tonight
the black Twitter to white boy pipeline
for language is one that is not lost on
me massive words like bus in No Cap
um it's just it's I find it's so funny
and one of my friends is tapped in hard
to Black Twitter and he will be able to
tell me about trends that are going to
happen six months before they do so
there definitely is a trickle-down
effect coming from black Twitter one
thing that I read uh
probably about six months or a year ago
now a judge in New York had had to work
out the interpretation of an emoji
because a big chunk of a case rested on
what this Emoji had meant in the form of
the conversation
I'm not surprised that probably did
happen yes I haven't heard of that
specific case but we actually find a lot
of hip-hop lyrics being used in criminal
trials to the detriment of of defendants
usually because of the misinterpretation
well a lot of times rappers for example
will be put on trial and we're not
talking about well big name rappers but
just sort of everyday people that have
rap as part of what they do and you know
rap music is built on sort of the
experience of being in a place where you
know you're fearful for your life you're
having to fight a lot of times it's sort
of machismo as well it's rebuilding
yourself up it's not truthful or
necessarily reflective of anything that
actually happened but lyrics can be very
misogynistic and very violent and in
cases where the hip-hop
um sort of lyrics were done by the
defendant they've been used in those
trials to suggest that they were
actually talking about what they had
done uh this is not performance art this
is an indication of what this person's
true nature is like absolutely and not
only that but actually if we look
research on when defendants or Witnesses
used
English when giving their depositions or
when being a witness at a trial or when
speaking on their own behalf the
outcomes for them tend to be much more
negative than the outcomes for a speaker
that would have used more mainstream
English so there are a lot of problems
with the way that we interpret
African-American English even though we
glorified in some contexts young white
men love it but they what they don't do
is recognize the negatives that are
faced by people that use
African-American English and can't just
put it on the way that they do yeah part
of the reason as well is with the the
white guys on Tick Tock that are using
the language trickled down from black
Twitter is that it it feels a little bit
like a lop right it's them playing with
the language as opposed to being locked
into it as opposed to it being almost
native it's something else so one of the
um one of my favorite stories that I
came up with I'd learned from a few
years ago was the
um development of goodbye
going from God be with you to God be
with ye to just goodbye
have you got a favorite or any other
favorite word stories of where something
developed from that we all use nowadays
well one of my favorite is um hello
right because actually hello was in
competition when the phone was first
created as a way to answer and it hello
used to be used in British English for
Sailors a lot of time I mean not sorry
for Sailors but for people that wanted
to call to someone who was not near them
so if someone was walking across the
street you wanted to get their attention
it would sort of be a way to to yell out
at them hello hello you know like look
over here dude I'm here it wasn't a
greeting in the way that we use it today
and it certainly wasn't the way you
answered the the telephone but
um I think it was Alexander Bell and
Thomas Edison were having a little war
at the beginning of the phone creation
about what should be the way that you
get someone's attention on the other
line because the old phone lines didn't
have a ring or anything you'd have to
say something like someone be walking
through the house you'd be like hello
hello pay attention so you'd say it
because it was the same sort of
attention-getting device as yelling to
someone on the street but Alexander Bell
who had created a similar technology as
Edison but you know for a competing I
think it was um model right for a
competing group he thought Ahoy made
more sense so people just say Ahoy when
they answered the phone because this was
a way you greed you know people on a
ship so he would answer the phone Ahoy
Ahoy that was his attention getting way
but obviously what happened is uh Edison
went out in the end and the reason is
because in the first phone book when
they were giving instructions about how
to use the phone instead of Ahoy they
suggested hello
and so that was really the way that
hello won out for our attention when we
wanted to talk on the phone or just now
when we greet each other so we think of
hello as being this early long-term
formal way to do it but it's actually
instead of Ahoy which I think we should
go back to Ahoy because I kind of like
that
what about high is high short for hello
I think I don't know the history of high
so much but I'm pretty sure it is uh
short for hello
um I'm not sure I remember I know I've
read that but it's been a long time I'm
trying to think about what Ahoy and
hello have in common they're both
similar sounds they both don't have any
hard like plosives or any of those
fricatives or there's not it's the sort
of thing I imagine that you could shout
at a pretty loud volume quite easily is
that what's what's a Hawaiian hello what
do they have in common well hello is is
voiced right a lot of voiced sound which
can be louder and vowels which are the
loudest and high I think you know I'm
I'll be curious I'll have to look up the
history of high and figure out how it
happens but a lot of times something
might be optimal in its full form but we
as speakers tend to like to shorten
things and so it probably just came up
in sort of a simple greeting of a
shortening of hello a lot of times what
we'd see is these things happen when
people are very intimate and they know
each other well they sort of do these
little cute shortenings of things and so
high probably evolved that way it's not
that different than any other word that
would have a vowel because all words
have to have a vowel so high on its own
doesn't stand out more than any other
word because basically high is just a a
vowel sound hello has two syllables so
we give you two chances to get someone's
attention and L's which starts the
second syllable or tend to be louder
than a voiceless consonant so that could
be it but I don't know from a sound
symbolism standpoint that they've
studied hello there are a lot of
interesting sound symbols some studies
but I don't think hello has been among
them
your area of work is absolutely
fascinating I think it's so interesting
to look at the it's almost like
linguistic archeology in a way it
actually you know a lot of um
anthropologists studied Linguistics so
Linguistics in the special the field I
do is kind of a cross between sociology
and linguistic anthropology so we look
back in time that's really cool some of
the old socio-historical Linguistics
where they go back and we try to
recreate How Sound change happened by
looking at written documents but in
modern speech I get to go out and
interview people and talk to them and
figure out what they're doing
differently so you know for example
Chris I could record you stick you on a
machine and then sort of do an analysis
of your vowels and sort of show just by
looking at your vowels I would be able
to tell who's Chris versus you know
who's a American male just from where
your vowels are positioned you know and
plus you're our lists right so you
delete your r's post vocalically have
you not noticed that you've probably
noticed who he says I'm like the the
instead of there or here you're right
you don't have your r's you have that'll
be the northeast of the UK I've managed
to reintroduce I had a brutally bad
glottal stop uh because yeah you don't
have really gladdle stops that stand out
not too bad but that's been I've worked
with the vocal coach miles for two years
now
um to try and just give myself a little
bit more of a middle England I already
did quite a lot I didn't have a massive
Northeast of the UK but when I was
growing up I would miss the teas out of
the word butter and I'd get slapped on
the back of my wrist by my mum who would
say there's two T's in butter
Christopher and you're not pronouncing
either of them
um
which is just half the course Northeast
of the UK that's the way that you would
speak right well now if you're American
you don't have any teas in that butter
well it's actually called a flap it's
actually called a flap but that's a
that's for a different episode so and
you know that's an interesting right
because you have the glottal stop which
is a perfect example of a feature that
has a really strong social stigma
attached and what I study is why do we
get these really strong social feelings
about something that's a sound you know
glottal stop is a sound and when if you
say the word up
every English speaker if they say the
word up actually has a glottal stop at
the beginning of that word so think
about up you can feel that your glottis
catches right it's because you're making
a glottal stop so no one you know
criticize criticizes you when you're
saying uh but yet if you say but or what
oh my God like you know linguistic
argument our argument art no argument
what's that Eve I can't even say that
word it's it's linguistic hell
so that's a perfect feature there that
exemplifies why I study what I study
okay but if you gave a great example of
your R so you said yes
instead of years yes that's two another
one is yeah you I get the piss taken out
if we buy a lot of friends for years and
years but it's years right that's a
perfect and you know that's a
fascinating one for me from historical
perspective because that is really sort
of high-class British speech right to
drop your r's so if you have your r's
not so not so fabulous in Britain Now in
America if you drop your RS you're you
know kind of pretentious and uppity or
you're a New Yorker right you're either
a New Englander and you're like a
brahmana you know kind of upper class or
you're a New Yorker and you just sound
cool
but generally Americans don't do it but
fascinating fact about those ours is
British speakers until the 19th century
did it because it was considered bad
English to not have your r's but in the
19th century flipped around because it
started to be the way that speakers
women particularly in court in the you
know Royal Court spoke and then it
became cool to drop your r's but prior
to that you actually will find write-ups
from the 1700s that criticized that
nasty vulgar are dropping that some
British speakers in London I'm part of
the new era of our dropping okay you're
the cool Suave our dropper thank you I
knew I knew that you would understand
all of the people in America that take
the piss out of me for the way that I
say yours no longer need to because I
have the seal of approval from someone
who's professionally trained yeah well I
mean Americans love British accents so I
don't think you have to
I was talking to
a very very success
who has a regional dialect he doesn't
like and so on his voicemail he had a
British speaker record it for him
because you know British speech is so
fancy
well look if if my accent is a
competitive advantage over here then
I'll take it as a win given the fact
that I had to survive uh Independence
Day last year which was very difficult
for me personally obviously as I was
watching watching your country dance on
the ashes of Mines lost ambition uh but
look why should people go if they want
to check out more of the work that you
do because this is fascinating well
first of all it's been really fun to
talk to you about it and uh yes I think
if you're looking for a second career
sociolinguistics would be for you but if
people want to learn more about me they
can obviously pick up my book which is
like literally dude but you can also go
to my website which is just
valeriefregland.com and you can read
some of my other work and sort of learn
about the types of research I do you can
even participate in a research study if
you click on that link there's all sorts
of fun to be had there Valerie I
appreciate you thank you sure thanks for
having me what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace